[Music]
i hate dust too
because it's just only a running gun
i just think some maps are pretty boring
like
dust2 my's favorite map is
dust 2. i can't cross to my bomb site
without being shot at
gary is going to be waiting he
co-charges in doesn't check
what oh my god inhuman reactions
on crimson's flusher in the back lines
he's out of ammo a knife is out what's
happening
it's their cheese side where they really
struggle
he's trapped behind the box he gets a
shot he goes he's gonna hit it off
dennis and now it's all gonna go
he gets a shot oh my god for simple to
actually get through this he's gonna
throw the awp in oh my god what is
happening
they're ready to shoot some ducks as
they cross the middle it's going to be a
challenge and
gameplay
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again
[Music]
as with any sequel we can't talk about
the story of dusk
2 without talking about dust the first
after being unveiled for the first time
in november 1999
de dust quickly solidified itself as not
only counter-strike's most popular map
but the one with the craziest origin
story
one november my little brother went out
with my mum into the shops
and she asked him what would you want to
a birthday present for dave
and he went yes and they just happened
to pick up half-life that that day
um that evening my mom told told my
little brother robert said just
go and hide it yeah just ready for his
birthday uh instead he tried to install
the family pc
and play it himself at which point i
found out
and from that evening i was hooked on
half-life and the same evening i found
out the half-life came with the
world craft mapping tool dust wasn't the
product of a seasoned map maker
or a soon-to-be designer at valve it was
hand crafted by dave
johnston a 16 year old from suffolk who
discovered a half-life mod
called counter-strike and needed
something to do on his summer vacation
you know the map in me got interested i
started looking on the files and found
a c strike dot wad which was a counter
strike uh
texture file filled with all these
real-life style
textures brickwork tiles concrete all
these things are different
all the half-life texts we had attempted
to be making maps with up to that time
and so i started making my very first
count strike map that evening
and after catching the attention of the
game's co-creators with his first map
cs tire dave was given the objective of
creating something new
that could launch with counter-strike's
next beta release
early on when we were developing the
community feedback would
basically color our next beta release
there was so much energy at that time
and so many fans who really felt like
they were
part of the development people were just
submitting so much content
we were getting maps i don't know maybe
100 a week
known for its all too recognizable
arches roadways and desert aesthetic
dave's inspiration for de dust stemmed
from his adolescent obsession
with early screenshots of team fortress
2
brotherhood of arms well they said
they'll hook him up with a
texture artist which happens to be
mcmahon aka chris ashton
and basically okay you know criticism
will help you make make some textures
what do you want i told christian okay
i want these team fortress 2 screenshots
and so i said okay please just make
these screenshots
and he did he made you know perfect
effects dimmies off these screenshots
and i started copying out the first part
of this team fortress 2 map that i've
seen in these screenshots
and that's how dust was worn funnily
enough dave didn't think twice about
taking inspiration from team fortress
since he figured that only a handful of
people would ever
see his map never mind load into it
but as we now know d e dust was what
you'd refer to
as an instant classic in addition to
being one of the first maps where the
objective was to focus on a bomb plant
players found the layout to be
accessible intuitive
and easy to learn
[Music]
within no time the 24 7 dust servers
were alive
and filled to the brim come the new year
valve had acquired counter-strike
from that point on dust had cemented
itself
as the most popular map in any first
person shooter
so it was only natural that the game's
ever growing community
expected a sequel especially since it
quickly became
all too clear that dust wasn't
especially suitable for high level play
a point brought up by the war owl but as
we all know
dust isn't really a great layout for a
competitive map
it's fundamentally flawed in that
respect terrorists rush a single
narrow hallway the only way into the
bomb site and the terrorists don't
really have that many options to move
around the map there's no
mid game every round plays out nearly
the same way
the issue is that for dave producing a
second dust
worthy of the name felt like an
impossible task
so in an effort to thwart expectations
he set out to construct
dust 3. his reasoning being that the
third installment in a movie franchise
is almost always inferior to the first
and with cs 1.1
the world was finally introduced to what
will become the most
iconic influential and ubiquitous fps
map
ever made dust2 it didn't take
long for dust 2 to solidify itself as
the locus of both
casual and competitive action as it
quickly became the go-to stomping
grounds in public servers
and eventually professional tournaments
unlike its predecessor dust 2's scrappy
yet structured layout
was both built and balanced around
competitive play
sure it lent itself to casual
run-of-the-mill rowdiness
but it was also a place where masters
could test their metal
the layout of dust 2 is its greatest
strength it is what would become defined
as the four
square layout consider a two by two
square grid where the edges denote the
passageways on the map
now consider the layout of dust two it
almost perfectly follows this design the
only anomaly being short a
connecting to the bomb site instead of
into the side of long a
this layout gives both teams tactical
options the terrorists can use the
middle passageways
to rotate between the two bomb sites and
find an opening
and fake out their opponents and the
counter-terrorists can rotate between
them
to try and be in the right position for
when the terrorists decide to push
if either team sees an opening they can
push through to take a positional
advantage
or end up in a fire fight to determine
who gets to keep that positional
advantage
for over a decade dust 2 stood as one of
the internet's
most recognizable hangouts and a literal
second home
to counter-strikers across the globe in
addition to teaching newcomers the
fundamentals
it engendered some of the hypest
highlights this fabled franchise
has ever seen
and not just in 1.6 the map was given a
facelift as part of counter-strike
source's release in 2004 and
in spite of the game's relative
unpopularity as an esport
dust's ever popular successor continued
to set the stage
for dazzlers everywhere 2 before dragons
in big trouble
fragmaster is looking strong 1v4 now
scream is a big jump on his hands
he gets one onto instead he gets another
one that's three
screams spamming away neal doesn't get
the defuse and
scream and now here comes azk up the
catwalk another nice shot
after taking down fcl now we're in a one
on one versus doctor strangelove here
he knows that he is under him this is
going decide nine six or ten five azk
coming around the corner
and is able to take him doctor strings
about to now we're got a 10
to five half but it wasn't until the
wildly anticipated launch of global
offensive in 2012
that johnston's masterpiece and
counter-strike at large
could truly be said to have entered the
modern era
and what an era it would shape up to be
garrett is going to be waiting heco
charges in dust and chicken
oh my god kenny s with three insane
kills
1v2 running up here p250 out jumping and
shooting he gets one more
kill looking forward he's got him hunted
down time is up oh my god
you're already gonna be kidding me he
gets the last kill in
one second left nitro does have a boss
of another smoke so it could be really
rough for simple to actually get through
this he's gonna throw the awp
oh my god simple why is happening
here's the thing though as cs go became
more competitive
so too did it become more studied
sophisticated
and strategic with rosters theory
crafting
angles rotations and executes like never
before
a demand arose for maps that rewarded
such intricate
tactical play best map in cs go would
have to
be a toss-up between overpass and nuke
for me
for nuke at least it's like very
tactical and like
there's a lot of things that um go into
like actually playing it well
and then for overpass there's a lot of
space and
it's like also very tactical as well so
it's like yeah
just like you can have freedom to do
what you want but at the same time you
have to be smart about it
dust2 on the other hand in spite of its
immortal status
the map was well kind of a [ __ ] show
it was open expansive was impossible for
the cts to rotate on
and had all but cemented itself as this
puggy
snowballing nightmare where cerebral big
brained counter-strike
was eschewed in favor of holding down
your w
key in fact it was probably johnston
himself who put it best
if dust is a map for casual matches dust
2 is a map
for organized massacres with a stunning
shot
a shot down olofmeister it's now a 4v4
jw still alive can he gets a kill
on crims rusher in the back lines he's
out of ammo
a knife itself what's happening
it's going to be a 2v2 no balls and
there
it was the one place where pretending
you were in a death match server could
actually be a very viable strategy it's
time
it's time james it's time for
counter-strike again
i don't get too attached to it oh my god
okay
all right then oh jw you see sir
oh my god james what's going on
they're all dead what just happened
what what just happened oh my god
now to be fair that wasn't always a bad
thing
dust who is was and always will be
an aimer's paradise the wild west of
counter-strike
you can get reverse steamrolled on your
own map pick if you're going to run the
risk of mirage desk 2 because they're so
aim-centric maps that if one team just
gets hot
individually they will destroy you and
he has been top fragging for a very long
time here on dust2
it's on shotshit at 103 to try and keep
it alive otherwise we'll go to a fifth
map in the grand finals
shots tabs out one that's a deadly kill
goes for the second and he's moving
closer
looking for the quad clutch here fnx the
last man alive he's going to tap the
bomb once
the issue is that often times it felt as
if the map's aim-centric structure
was a little too abusable for casuals
this could be both
unfriendly and unwelcoming dust 2 is
somewhat t-side friendly which is nice
but the worst thing about the map for me
is the
opera playing middle imagine a new
player trying csgo for the first time
and while they're busy looking around
the buy menu for what shotgun they want
to use they get spawn killed not a great
introduction to the game
for competitors it could be infuriating
exploitative
and sometimes downright stupid your awp
they're ready to shoot some ducks as
they cross the middle it's going to be a
challenge and
if it's not in this lifetime
question is can they actually get a kill
initially
unfortunately the layout had become too
mythological to incur
any major changes this was made
resoundingly clear
early on in 2017 when dust 2 was removed
from the active duty pool and given a
complete cosmetic makeover
but as three clicks philip rightly
observed that was just about
all it got all in all this map is still
dust too in all the ways that matter
but you may find yourself somewhat
disappointed besides
dust2's problem was never the messy
corners or the graphics but rather that
it had been played to death
something that visual overhaul won't fix
upon the release of what the community
termed
dust new the map was literally afforded
its own
category in the client it was slotted
back into competitive play in the spring
of 2018
and quickly regained its status as the
so-called quintessential counter-strike
map look at the start menu
pardon our dust look at what it says
below perhaps the
quinten tessi intel
quinte excuse me
last time i checked i'm a youtuber not a
quantum physicist
unlike virtually every other one of
counter-strike staple battlegrounds
dust2 has never once had a substantial
rework
it's remained exactly the same an
immortal
untouchable inimitable icon
part of the reason for this is that it
doesn't need to be changed
dust 2 is undeniably a master class in
map design
why is dust 2 still played today it
never gets
boring it gets old it gets overplayed it
grows mold but it never
gets boring but the other reason
is that it's simply too big to change
dust 2 is quite literally as old as
counter-strike itself
a piece of the very soul of this
hallowed franchise
we all hold so dear especially because
the ct side is their better side it's
their t-side where they really struggle
scream and has to immediately fall
backwards
he wants this madness he's picking up
behind the lines he's gonna get the kill
on sidney
simple he needs a multi-kill first found
twist aggressing they have to double
peak he's getting his shots he's hitting
another one
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again
it's been replicated in virtually every
map maker
ever made and with good reason dust 2
has been engendering good old-fashioned
mayhem
for nearly 20 years across a variety of
titles
most of which aren't even related to
counter-strike
one more long one more long elevator now
i still want plants got them nice
they're already here already
got them i found them
i found them no i'm dead
did he get you whether we like it or not
what was once a 16 year old's passion
project
has since evolved into the single most
iconic map
in the whole of esports the be-all and
end-all
of places to bout a bastion of beautiful
belligerent [ __ ] coldzera is waiting
for this push from street but he's gonna
tuck himself into the corner coldzera
though is a bit of a freak and i have to
imagine he's gonna clear this
oh no go god i love it
yes stewie's got that and the follow-up
really been playing great elise humans
do it both in fact
yeah that is oh how bad are you right
now and twist in the corner there should
be no way out my god
how has he done it picking up a quick
triple and he's going to win the round
absolutely godlike
simple i swear if you do anything
ridiculous now i am going to
oh there it is just ridiculous
no absolutely not he made me sound like
a gorilla
dust2 is not perfect and it shouldn't be
because honestly for as much as we
complain
we wouldn't have it any other way
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages